In this Cloud Minute I'm going to show you how to
add an Uptime Check to your project.
From the developer's console click Monitoring and then
click Dashboards & alerts
This is going to open up a new tab.
You may need to enable monitoring if you haven't already for your project.
Next to the words "Uptime Checks"
click Create Check
I want to do an HTTP check against a URL
I'm going to put in my hostname
and I want to check the path index.html
Just to make sure everything is working correctly I'm going to click test.
And since I got a 200/OK I'm going to click save.
If I want to be notified when my site goes down
I need to create an alerting policy.
There are several notification methods
available but I'm going to choose email.
I click add notification and then type my email address.
Once that done I can click save policy.
Now that the policy is saved
I will be notified by email when my site goes down.
I hope you found this helpful.